Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und nach einer kleinen Winterpause nehmen wir hier das Programm wieder auf mit der 51. Sendung. Und heute steht eine ganz spezielle Mission im Mittelpunkt. Das XMM-Newton-Weltraumteleskop und was es damit auf sich hat, das erklärt uns heute Markus Kirsch.
Guten Morgen.
Ja, wir sind, das muss ich gleich noch dazu sagen, wieder einmal in Darmstadt gelandet, hier beim ESOG, beim Raumkontrollzentrum. Und ja, da bist du ja auch täglich am Arbeiten an dem XMM. Was ist deine konkrete Aufgabe, beziehungsweise eine offizielle Visitenkartenbezeichnung?
Ich habe gar keine Visitenkarte mehr, weil sich das so oft ändert bei uns hier. Aber mein Job heißt, glaube ich, Spacecraft Operations Manager. Das heißt, ich bin verantwortlich für den Flugbetrieb von unseren Satelliten hier. Ich kümmere mich also mit einem Flugkontrollteam von Ingenieuren und Spacecraft-Controllern um den täglichen Ablauf, damit der Satellit da hinschaut, wo er hinschauen soll.
Der XMM ist ja schon etwas länger unterwegs, wird, wie wir vielleicht auch gleich noch hören werden, noch ein bisschen länger fliegen. Seit wann begleitest du das Projekt selber?
Ich bin bei der ESA jetzt seit 2002, glaube ich, oder 2001 habe aber viel früher schon bei XMM angefangen, im Studium schon, das war so glaube ich 96, wenn ich mich richtig richtig erinnere. Und zwar kam das dadurch, dass ich an der Uni Tübingen studiert habe damals, Math und Physik, und bin dann irgendwann mal ein bisschen in die Astronomie-Richtung auch gegangen und hatte damals eine Vorlesung gehört beim Herrn Staubert. Das war so die Riege damals, Staubert und Professor Trünper von Max Planck, die kannten sich ganz gut und die Uni Tübingen war involviert, eine Kamera zu bauen für XMM. Und da bin ich da so ein bisschen reingerutscht, habe angefangen, einen Heavy-Job zu machen in der Astronomie in Tübingen. Und irgendwann hat man jemand gesucht, der Kalibration macht für zwei Satelliten damals. Das war der XMM-Newton, hieß damals nur XMM-Newton, hieß er dann erst nach dem Start. Und ABRICSAS, das war ein deutscher Satellit. Und für beide haben wir die Kameras gebaut damals. Und ich war in der Kalibration aktiv. Kalibration heißt, man schaut sich an, wie die Kameras funktionieren, wie die Kameras performen und versucht dann für die Wissenschaftler, die Daten korrekt zu machen. Denn Kameras haben immer Eigenschaften in der Verstärkung, die nicht zum Beispiel ganz linear sind oder nicht ganz in Ordnung sind. Es gibt in solchen Kameras auch schlechte Pixel, die mal hell oder dunkel werden und so was. Und das kann man im Nachhinein aus den Daten rausrechnen. Beziehungsweise kann man die Kamera auch schon im Vorhinein, bevor man die Beobachtung macht, auf eine gewisse Art kalibrieren und einstellen, sodass diese Fehler oder nicht unbedingt Fehler, sondern spezielle Beschaffeneinfamilien, Funktionsunterschiede rausgenommen werden können.
Bist du denn Mathematik und Physik, hast du gesagt?
Ich wollte Lehrer werden.
Ja, also du hattest den Weltraum erst mal gar nicht so im Kopf.
Nein, der Weltraum kam erst später dazu. Ich wollte eigentlich Klassik und Physik machen, das hat mich so interessiert. Ich war auch für mein Lehramt da ganz interessiert, Leuten was beizubringen. Ich habe viel in der Lehre gemacht, in den Praktika geholfen. Das mit der Astronomie, das hat eigentlich zwei Gründe gehabt. Einer ist ganz witzig. Natürlich war die Faszination für die Wissenschaft da, für die Astronomie. Das kam durch Herrn Staubert, der mich da echt fasziniert hat damals. Aber der richtige, ausschlaggebende Punkt war ein ganz anderer. Ich habe damals auch Musik gemacht in einer Band. Wir haben Studioaufnahmen gemacht und ich habe Geld gebraucht, um die CD, hieß das damals noch, da hat man keine Podcasts gemacht, um die CD zu bezahlen. Ich bin dann auch von Institut zu Institut und habe gesagt, wo kann man denn einen Heavy-Job machen? Die Astronomen kannte ich schon, ein bisschen von der Vorlesung. Die haben gesagt, pass auf, da gibt es halt diese Projekte XMM, du musst dann nach München fahren, Nachtschicht, Kalibration machen, geht das. Ich habe gesagt, wenn das 5000 Euro bringt, D-Mark waren das damals, dann mache ich das. Und da wurde es dann aktiv, da bin ich richtig ins Projekt reingerutscht.
Also bist du sozusagen als Sternsinger aufgetaucht.
Als Sternsinger, genau, als Sternsinger aufgetaucht. Leider ist das mit der Band dann nichts geworden, oder Gott sei Dank, who knows. Und in der Promotion, als ich dann angefangen habe zu promovieren, da wurde es dann immer mehr XMM und immer weniger Musik. Und das war dann so ein zweiter Zufall, wie ich dann zur ESA gekommen bin. Ich war immer noch in Tübingen mit meiner Promotion beschäftigt, habe mich damals mit Neutronensternen beschäftigt. Also schnell rotierende Objekte, die ziemlich klein sind und massereiche. Das ist eine Neutronenstern, kann man sich vorstellen, Masse unserer Sonne, aber zusammengedrückt so auf 10, 15 Kilometer. Also da hat man wirklich keine normale atomare Masse mehr, sondern die Elektronen, die drücken sich quasi in die Kerne rein und produzieren dann in Neutronen, schwierig zu beschreiben, Gebilde. Das ist also sehr dicht wie Kernmaterie und sehr schwer und sehr interessant. Die drehen sich dann auch ganz schnell, es sieht dann aus wie so ein blinkender Leuchtturm im Universum. Und das kann man beobachten, auch mit unserem XMM ziemlich schön. Und ich habe da in Timing-Kalibrationen darauf gearbeitet während der Promotion. Und dann gab es irgendwann, nach dem Start, ich habe den Start auch begleitet von der Kalibration von der PI-Seite, PI heißt Principle Investigator. Die ESA macht das ja immer so, dass die Instrumente oft von Instituten gebaut werden, also nicht bei der ESA selbst. Und ich habe bei solchem Institut da halt mitgemacht. Und die brauchen am Anfang Unterstützung von Leuten, die sich auskennen. Und da hat man jemanden gesucht, der in Spanien die ersten Jahre die Mission begleitet, den ESAC. Also nicht hier ESOC, sondern European Space Astronomy Center in Spanien. Damals war das noch viel kleiner, hieß damals Wildspar Villa Franca Tracking Station. Und da habe ich dann angefangen für die ESA zu arbeiten, aber noch quasi von der Uni bezahlt als Experte. Und habe dann 2000 mich auf die Stelle von meinem Chef beworben bei der ESA und wollte das eigentlich mal ausprobieren, ob es wie so ein Interview ist, weil meine Doktorzeit war dann so ziemlich vorbei und ich brauchte einen Job. Und da habe ich gedacht, das kann ich mal ganz gut üben, wie das ist. Den Job kriege ich sowieso nicht. Und dann haben die mir das angeboten. Und dann bin ich dann acht Jahre, sieben und halb Jahre, in Spanien geblieben, damals auf der wissenschaftlichen Seite. Und dann hier nach ESA gekommen, 2008.
Und dann hier in diese Rolle?
In diese Rolle. Ich war ja immer schon XMM, mehr auf der Kalibration, so ein Instrumentseite. Wobei die Kalibration dann so nach sechs, sieben, acht Jahren nach dem Start dann für meine, wie ich das sehe, eigentlich erledigt war. Es ging dann nicht mehr so um große Änderungen, sondern da hat man im Prozentbereich gearbeitet von der Genauigkeit. Und das war mir dann ein bisschen langweilig. Und das waren halt in meinen Augen Kleinigkeiten, darf man natürlich so nicht sagen. Es gibt immer noch Leute, die da arbeiten und da sehr wertvolle Arbeit machen. Aber für mich war das nicht mehr so interessant. Ich wollte mal was Neues wieder machen und dann gab es eine Möglichkeit, hier zur ESA zurückzukommen und dann das Ganze, den ganzen Satellit sicher ranzuschauen. Und das war für mich ein Schritt zurück auch zur Physik. Weil in der Physik macht man ja nicht nur Astronomie, sondern alles Mögliche. Und beim Spacecraft hat man wirklich alles. Du hast Tralräder, die sich drehen, also mechanische Sachen, wo natürlich auch Elektronik mit reinspielt, du hast ein Treibstoffsystem, mit dem du so ein Satellit drehen kannst oder die Räder entladen. Da spielen Drücke, Thermodynamik eine Rolle. Du hast Sonnenstrahlung, die du aufhängst mit Solar Areas, um Strom zu machen. Also man hat da so ein bisschen von der ganzen Physik. Und das fand ich ganz spannend, da in der Richtung wieder einzusteigen. Und natürlich das Ding auch am Leben zu halten. Das ist doch eine interessante Aufgabe, dass man so ein Satellit eigentlich viel länger fliegen kann, als ursprünglich vorgesehen.
Jetzt hast du ja schon Joachim Trümper erwähnt. Der war ja hier auch schon mal zu Gast bei Raumzeit. Und da haben wir uns über, ja eigentlich kann ich sagen, so die, das finde ich gerade keinen guten Namen dafür, aber es ist schon so eine der meistbeachteten Missionen in diesem Segment gewesen, der ROSAT. Darüber haben wir uns unterhalten, den er ja maßgeblich mitentwickelt und dann betrieben hat und auch eben lange über Röntgenastronomie gesprochen. Das sollten wir natürlich auch nochmal tun, weil XMM ist, wurde ja schon erwähnt, ein Röntgen-Weltraumteleskop, das heißt, blickt ins All und schaut sich eben genau diesen spezifischen Frequenzbereich an. Was ist denn das Verhältnis von Newton zu seinen Vorgängerprojekten und warum kam es überhaupt zu dieser Mission? Was war da sozusagen der Erkenntnisgewinn aus den vorherigen Missionen, dass man gesagt hat, da müsse man jetzt auch nochmal nachbohren?
Das ist ein guter Punkt. Also der ROSAT war ja schon noch mal eine ganze Nummer kleiner als der XMM. Das war ja damals, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, in den 90ern, 90 gestartet worden oder so. Und der hat da hauptsächlich erstmal auch einen Survey gemacht, um möglichst viele Objekte zu finden. Der XMM ist nicht eine Survey-Mission, sondern der XMM ist eine Pointing-Mission. Das heißt, wir haben ein kleines Gesichtsfeld und schauen irgendwo ganz tief ins Universum rein, können weit reinschauen, tief, aber haben nicht so ein großes Gesichtsfeld, dass wir ganz, ganz viele Objekte sehen. Das ist auch nicht unser Ziel, denn wir wollten natürlich neue Objekte finden, aber wir wollten hauptsächlich auch Objekte, die schon bekannt sind, genauer anschauen.
Also ROSAT, das war ja eigentlich erstmal das Vermächtnis, dass man überhaupt erstmal so mit so einer, also für damalige Verhältnisse, sehr hohen Auflösungen hat schauen können, sich aber alles angeschaut hat, quasi das Ei aus dem Blickwinkel der Erde kategografiert hat im Röntgenbereich und festgestellt hat, oha, da ist ja eine Menge los.
Da ist eine Menge los, genau. Also vorher hatte man nur die Möglichkeit, mit Ballons oder mit sounding rockets, also so Parabolflüge zu machen, so hat man angefangen in 60ern, 70ern Jahren. Dann gab es ein paar andere Satelliten wie der Uhuru, das war ja der erste in dem Bereich, der dann schon mal angefangen hat, mehrere Objekte zu finden, aber die ganze Zeit beobachten konnte. Und der ROSAT hat dann zum ersten Mal so eine große Karte gemacht. Und mit dem XMM wollte man einen Schritt weiter gehen, daraus kommt der Name. XMM heißt X-Ray Multi-Mirror-Mission und das Malti ist das Wichtige dabei. Also viele, viele Spiegel wollten wir haben. Und damals hat man diese Technik sich überlegt, Spiegel ineinander zu schachteln. Und wir haben drei große Spiegelsysteme. Das sieht aus wie diese russischen Puppen, die so ineinander, ein Spiegel namen, dann ist die Matroschkas. Und dadurch kriegen wir diese große, effektive Fläche. Das heißt, wenn ich nur einen Spiegel hätte, dann würde die Strahlung hier rankommen. Die macht streifenden Einfall. Bei Röntgenstrahlung ist das ja ganz wichtig. Ich kann da nicht eine normale Linse nehmen, da würde die Strahlung ja durchgehen. Das heißt, ich kann die nur reflektieren, wenn ich sie in einem ganz flachen Winkel einstrahle. Und wenn ich das mit so einem Spiegel mache, nur einem, dann habe ich natürlich, wenn ich da so schräg draufschaue, die effektive Fläche ist ja ganz klein. Das ist ja nur die Projektion. Und deshalb, wenn ich dann viele Spiegel ineinander setze, kann ich meine effektive Fläche größer machen. Und das hat man damals gemacht.
Was heißt jetzt ineinander? Dass das so wie so ein Fliegenauge aussieht, so ein fast ein Auge oder so?
Nee, nicht wie ein Fliegenauge, sondern du hast quasi einen Kreis und dann hast du noch einen Kreis und noch einen Kreis und noch einen Kreis.
Was war das denn so? Ringe?
Das sind Paraboloide und Hyperboloide, die ineinander sind. Die werden immer kleiner. Und dadurch hast du aber als effektive Fläche wesentlich mehr, als wenn du nur einen äußeren Spiegel hast. Du musst ja forschen, du guckst da drauf, das sieht so ein bisschen schräg nur aus und du siehst dann nur die Projektion von dem. Also von dem riesen Spiegel, der nach hinten geht, siehst du nur so ein kleines Stück. Wenn du aber jetzt mehrere da reinmachst, dann hast du eine größere effektive Fläche. Und das ist der Trick beim XMM. Mit so drei solchen großen Spiegeln kannst du halt Beobachtungen machen, die nicht so lange dauern müssen und trotzdem ein sehr gutes Spektrum kriegen. Also da geht es jetzt gar nicht um Bilder, was unser amerikanischer Kollege Chandra besser kann als wir. Chandra ist mehr ausgelegt, um schöne Bilder zu machen. Aber wenn es ums Spektrum geht, um ein gutes Spektrum, dann sind wir wesentlich genauer und wesentlich schneller, weil wir halt die vielen Spiegel haben. Unsere Bilder sind nicht so gut wie die von Chandra, aber unsere Spektren können wesentlich schneller hergestellt werden. Also wir reden immer so von Kilosekunden-Bereich und so mit 10 Kilosekunden kann man bei uns schon ein vernünftiges Spektrum machen. Zehn Kilosekunden. Eine Stunde sind 3600 Sekunden, also so nach drei, vier Stunden. Je nachdem, wie hell das Objekt ist, bei manchen kann man auch nach fünf, sechs Kilosekunden vernünftiges Spektrum kriegen. Und wir fahren halt mehrere Instrumente parallel, das ist auch nochmal ein Unterschied. Wir haben also hinter den drei Teleskopen, die wir fliegen, haben wir zwei Spektroschrafen, Reflecting Grading Spectrometers heißt das, also ein Spektroskop sitzen. Und dann nochmal drei Kameras, die im Röntgenbereich beobachten und wir haben noch einen Optical Monitor, mit dem wir auch optisch und im Ultravioletten beobachten können.
Das heißt, zusammenzufassen, ROSAT und auch Tandra ist auch eher so Survey orientiert?
Ne, Tandra ist auch Pointing Observations. Survey macht mir im Moment eigentlich gar nichts, weil ROSAT da so eine große, ja so eine gute Karte geliefert hat, dass man damit heute noch sehr gut leben kann.
Okay, das heißt, man weiß einfach, wo die interessanten Punkte sind, sozusagen. Und jetzt hat man sich dem verpflichtet, mal diese interessanten Punkte genauer anzuschauen, während Tandra da mehr so in der Technik ausgelegt ist, dass man das mal schön abbilden kann, dass man da gute Bilder davon bekommt und eine Vorstellung davon bekommt, wie das da so ist. Ist jetzt XMM sozusagen darauf optimiert, auch wirklich das Spektrum abzubilden und das deute ich jetzt mal, als damit man einfach mal genau die Zusammensetzung dessen, was denn da nun tatsächlich aktiv ist, auch genau analysieren kann.
Über das Spektrum kann man was sagen, über die Elemente, die in so einem System drin sind, oder man kann was über die Temperaturen sagen, über die Magnetfelder, ja, über alle möglichen Begebenheiten in so einem System. Wenn du zum Beispiel eine aktive Galaxie anschaust, die kann man ja oft nicht auflösen, das ist jetzt so weit weg, oder ein Röntgen-Doppelsternsystem in einer benachbarten Galaxie kann man auch nicht auflösen, das ist nur punktförmig, das heißt, da hilft uns der Chandra auch nicht weiter, das kann der auch nicht sehen, der kann die zwei Sterne nicht sehen, aber über das Spektrum kannst du rausfinden und über die Lichtkurven, wie die zwei Sterne umeinander rumfliegen und wie Materie zum Beispiel von einem, dem sogenannten Begleitstern, auf den Neutronenstern zum Beispiel rüberfliegt und da einstürzt. Und wie heißt das, Virgin? Daraus kann man sich Sachen ausrechnen, wie das Magnet fällt, die Orbitperioden und und und bei so einem System. Und das kannst du über das Spektrum wesentlich besser machen, oder das kannst du nur über das Spektrum im Moment machen, weil wir einfach noch keine Teleskope haben, die in eine benachbarte Galaxie bei so was reinschauen können.
Aber das Spektrum ist schon beschränkt auf diesen Röntgenbereich?
Das Spektrum ist beschränkt auf den Röntgenbereich und zwar den niederenergetischen Röntgenbereich. Also wir können beobachten, von 0,2 Kilo Elektronenvolt bis 15 Kilo Elektronenvolt. Um ein Beispiel zu machen, kann man sich vielleicht schlecht vorstellen, diese Einheit. Ein normales Photon, das aus einer Lampe rauskommt, also so ein normales Licht, das hat so ungefähr einen Elektronenvolt an Energie. Also wie Astronomen in Röntgenastronomie denken, oder ich denke immer in so kugelförmigen Objekten, das sind meine Photonen und die fliegen da mit einer bestimmten Energie und die haben eine Farbe. Und die Farbe ist die Energie für mich. Unser normales Photon im optischen Bereich hat einen Elektronenvolt an Energie. Ein Röntgen-Photon hat einen Kilo Elektronenvolt, also ein Faktor 1000 mehr an Energie. Und die kannst du halt von der Erde gar nicht beobachten, weil die in der Atmosphäre stecken bleiben. Die werden rausgefiltert und deshalb müssen wir was hochschicken. Und unsere Kameras sind optimiert darauf, in dem Frequenzbereich, wir reden von einem Energiebereich, also 0,2kV bis 15kV zu beobachten. Darüber könnte man die Kameras sogar noch was messen, aber die Spiegel werden transparent. Das heißt, wenn Photonen mit einer höheren Energie kommen, fliegen die durch den Spiegel einfach durch. Der Spiegel kann die nicht mehr ablenken. Das ist dann wirklich wie Röntgenstrahlung, normalerweise geht die auch durch beim Arzt. Wir sind dabei im wesentlich niedrigen Energiebereich. Wenn man so zum Arzt geht, ist das noch mal wesentlich höher, die Energie.
Fällt einem es ein bisschen schwer, sich Spiegel vorzustellen, die jetzt nicht für sichtbares Licht bedienen? Aus was sind die denn gemacht?
Die XMM-Spiegel sind aus Formen gemacht, die dann mit Gold beschichtet worden sind. Das ist, glaube ich, ein Nickelmaterial gewesen. Da war ich selbst nicht involviert, da wurde ein Tauchbad gemacht. Da macht man dann eine Goldoberfläche drauf, die dann auch nochmal poliert werden muss. Die müssen also ziemlich glatt sein, ganz wenig Rauheit haben, weil sonst diese Röntgen-Fotonen auch wieder abgelenkt werden würden. Der Trick beim XMM war, dass man diese Formen mehrfach benutzen konnte. Normalerweise macht man den Spiegel einmal, dann schleift man den so lange, bis er gut ist. Wir konnten diese Mandrelz mehrfach benutzen, um mehrere Spiegelmodule zu generieren.
Mandrelz ist was?
Mandrelz ist das Ding, woran man den Spiegel dann abformt. Das ist quasi so eine Negativform. Da kommt dann ein Material drüber, in einem Tauchbad. Dann hat man die Grundform, und das muss man dann nochmal beschichten, um eine gute Reflexion zu kriegen. Das ist also eine Technik, die von einer italienischen Firma zusammen mit Manzais gemacht worden ist und die relativ gut funktioniert hat.
Ich frage jetzt in die falsche Richtung, wenn ich die wissenschaftlichen Aspekte nochmal aufgreife, weil ESA kümmert sich vor allem um den Betrieb. Das ist auch das, was wir hier im Wesentlichen in den Mittelpunkt packen wollen. Trotzdem, was waren denn so die Ziele, was hatte man denn im Sinn? Man wollte sich das genauer anschauen, jetzt gab es schon die Karte vom ROSAT. Man hatte sozusagen schon einen Überblick, was pickt man sich dann da raus?
Da gibt es ganz klare Kategorien, nach denen man das Programm am Anfang aufgebaut hat. Da gibt es erstmal natürlich Objekte, die nah bei uns sind, in unserer Galaxie, wie zum Beispiel Neutronensterne, deren Zeitverhalten man genauer anschauen wollte.
Sind die eigentlich selten? Es gibt von allem irgendwie genug, aber im Verhältnis zu den sonstigen Sternen?
Die sind seltener als normale Sterne, weil sie die Endentwicklung von Sternen sind. Nach einer gewissen Zeit bläht ein Stern sich irgendwann auf, wird dann zu einer Supernova und explodiert dann. Oder es bleibt noch etwas übrig. Wenn noch etwas übrig bleibt, dann kann da ein Neutronenstern draus entstehen, ein weißer Zwerg oder ein schwarzes Loch. Das heißt, per Definition hast du nicht so viele Neutronensterne übrig, wie du am Anfang Sterne hattest. Und die sind auch nicht unbedingt immer so hell, dass man die aus ganz weit entfernten Galaxien dann noch sehen kann. Das heißt, du siehst die halt nur bei uns in der Nähe.
Supernovae passieren jetzt auch nicht jeden Tag?
Supernovae passieren auch nicht so oft, aber du siehst die ja lange nachleuchten. Es ist nicht, dass der dann nur einmal kurz da ist. Und wenn so eine Supernova mal passiert ist, kannst du das lange, lange Zeit noch sehen. Also zum Beispiel ein Objekt, für das ich mich persönlich interessiere, der Crept-Nebel, der hat auch einen Neutronen-Stern drin. Diese Supernova war irgendwann 1000 nach Christus, ich glaube 1054, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Und seitdem kann man den sehen und der ist noch sehr hell und der wird auch noch viele, viele Jahre sichtbar sein. Das sind also so die näheren Objekte, diese Neutronen-Sterne, Röntgen-Doppel-Sterne, die es bei uns so in der Galaxie anzuschauen gibt. Dann kann man natürlich normale Sterne auch anschauen, also Sterne, die auch im Röntgenlicht strahlen. Unsere Sonne strahlt hier auch im Röntgenlicht. Die können wir leider nicht anschauen, weil die zu hell ist, würde unser Satellit nicht mitmachen. Aber es gibt natürlich andere Sterne in unserer Galaxie, die auch da interessant sind. Da gibt es ganz interessante Sachen anzuschauen, wie sich Winde zwischen den einzelnen, wenn man so ein Dobbensternsystem hat, da können dann so Sternwinde hin und her sich bewegen. Das ist ganz interessant. Das ist jetzt persönlich nicht mein Thema, aber das ist so ein Bereich, das ist alles sehr nah. Wenn man dann weiter weggehen will, dann ist man in der nächsten Galaxie. Da schaut man sich dann schon noch die Galaxie an mit ihren Einzelteilen. Da gibt es also auch wieder Objekte, die da interessant sind. Zum Beispiel können da schwarze Löcher drin sein im Zusammenhang wieder mit einem Begleitstern, wo man Masseüberfluss von einem aufs andere System sieht. Man kann mehr über die schwarzen Löcher lernen. Da haben wir einige neue Sachen gefunden. Das ist aber immer noch sehr nah. Das nächste, was man dann angucken kann, sind dann gesamte Galaxien. Dass man irgendwo wirklich nur noch eine Galaxie als Objekt anschaut und dann misst, wie viel Energie insgesamt von so einer Galaxie kommt. Da gibt es ganz interessante Galaxien, die heißen aktive Galaxien. Da ist in der Mitte ein massives schwarzes Loch drin. Es ist nicht ein schwarzes Loch, ein kleines. Es ist ja so, wenn ein Neutronenstern...
Kein herkömmliches, handelsübliches.
Wenn man sich die Theorie anschaut, dann ist es so ein Neutronenstern, wenn der ein bisschen schwerer wird. Wenn man dann bei 3-4 Sonnenmassen ist, dann ist die Gravitation so stark, dass das zusammenbricht an der Neutronenstern-Level zum schwarzen Loch. Das ist quasi so ein mini-schwarzes Loch. Die können dann größer werden, 10, 20, 30 Sonnenmassen können sie auch was einfangen. Aber von denen ich jetzt spreche, in der aktiven Galaxie, das sind massive schwarze Löcher. Da redet man von 10 hoch irgendwas Sonnenmassen, 10 hoch 6, 10 hoch 5, 10 hoch 7. Also unglaublich, unglaubliche An-
Aber Millionen von Sonnen, die an einem einzigen Punkt sich zusammenfallen.
Ja, an einem einzigen Punkt. Das kann dann auch ein Kilometer sein. Das ist nicht mehr ein Punkt. Riesig groß. Und die sitzen wirklich im Zentrum von der Galaxie.
Aber hat nicht jede Galaxie ein schwarzes Loch in der Mitte?
Ja, da ist man noch so am Überlegen. Das sieht so aus, als ob unsere Galaxie auch ein schwarzes Loch hat. Es gibt aber auch immer schwarze Löcher, die noch eine Zeit lang still sind, von denen man nichts sieht. Die nennt man schlafende schwarze Löcher. Die sind quasi still und melden sich nur, wenn mal wieder was reinfällt. Man kann ja vom schwarzen Loch an sich nichts sehen.
Also still im Sinne von, dass sie jetzt keine Strahlung imitieren.
Ja, die können mal ruhig sein. Und dann, wenn halt wieder was reinfällt, man sieht ja vom schwarzen Loch selbst nichts. Man sieht ja immer nur, wenn Material in das schwarze Loch reinfällt. Dann heizt sich das Material auf und kurz bevor das verschwindet, können sich Scheiben um solche schwarzen Löcher bilden. Und dann siehst du quasi die Hitze von dem Material, was da rein strudelt. Das sind Millionen von Grad. Wir reden ja immer von, ob wir da Kelvin oder Celsius reden, in der Röntgenastronomie ist es egal. Und das siehst du dann, diese Hitze. Wenn das mal hinter Event Horizon verschwunden ist, kann man nichts mehr sehen.
Event Horizon muss man noch mal kurz erläutern. Also wenn etwas ins schwarze Loch reinfällt und sozusagen so stark davon angezogen wird, dass nicht mal mehr das Licht hinaus treten kann, dann gibt es sozusagen kein Event mehr.
Und da sind natürlich dann objektiv weiterwechselnd, diese Galaxien. Und dann gibt es noch mal eine einzelne Sammlung. Das nennt sich Cluster of Galaxies. Das sind dann Galaxien, die sich in einer Gruppe zusammenfinden. Die kann man auch noch anschauen. Da können wir Aussagen machen über Gastemperaturen. Da gibt es so Gase, die innerhalb der einzelnen Galaxien sich irgendwie finden. Regionen, wo es ganz heiße Temperaturen von Gas gibt, das kann man dann noch mal als Großobjekt ansehen, sodass wir wirklich von klein nach groß gehen. Wir haben auch ganz kleine Sachen angeschaut, wie zum Beispiel Kometen. Das ist ja doch was ziemlich Kleines, wo man am Anfang gar nicht wusste, hat so ein Komet Röntgenstrahlung. Hat er, ist aber nur Reflektion von anderen Objekten. Also ein Komet an sich ist kalt. Da gibt es also Leute, die sich damit beschäftigen, mit der Röntgenstrahlung von Kometen. Also da gab es eine ganze Latte von wissenschaftlichen Bereichen, die man sich anschauen will. Und in jedem einzelnen Bereich hat man natürlich jetzt neue Dinge gefunden, spannende neue Dinge auch. Und jetzt zu sagen, das war das Tollste und das war das Beste, möchte ich an dieser Stelle gar nicht so machen. Das ist erstens die Aufgabe von unserem Project-Scientist. Und auch für den ist es immer schwierig zu sagen, das war das Interessanteste, weil dann sagen 100 Leute, aber meins war doch viel interessanter. Also ich denke, man muss den ganzen Bereich da sehen. Und was man vielleicht sehen muss bei XMM, ist die Anzahl der Publikationen, die wir machen. Denn wir haben eigentlich im Moment so 300 Publikationen pro Jahr, also Astronomie in Astrophysics oder APJ oder Science and Nature.
Was heißt die, die wir machen? Also die, die wir machen, ist falsch.
Also wir machen ja, wir stellen die ESA-Macht betreut in Satellit, wir stellen die Daten her und diese Daten gehen dann an Wissenschaftler. Und der Wissenschaftler, der eine Beobachtung angefragt hat, also einmal pro Jahr, vielleicht müssen wir da anfangen, einmal pro Jahr machen wir sogenanntes Announcement of Opportunity. Da können die Wissenschaftler auf der ganzen Welt oder auch du, ihr könnt sagen, ich möchte Objekt XYZ anschauen, weil das, das, das, das, das interessiert mich. Dann schickst du das an die ESA. Die ESA kriegt eine Anzahl von Proposals, nennen wir das, kann aber nur eine andere Anzahl von Proposals Y wirklich machen. Weil wir dauerhaft nicht mehr Zeit haben. Genau, mehr Zeit ist nicht da. Wir haben meistens 6-7 Mal mehr Anfragen, als wir eigentlich machen können. Das heißt, wir müssen das erst mal auswählen, was machen wir davon wirklich. Das ist dann ein externes Experten-Komitee, die schauen sich das an, irgendwelche schlauen Astronomen, die sagen, okay, das und das machen wir. Dann kriegen wir eine Liste von Objekten, die wir anschauen wollen. Das macht unser Science-Operation-Center in Spanien, in Villafranca. Das wird dann runtergebrochen auf ein Day-to-day-Schedule für uns hier in ESA. Wir genau wissen, heute gucken wir das und das an. Wenn wir dann die Beobachtung gemacht haben, werden die Daten schon mal ein bisschen vor.
Die Reihenfolge, ist das dann so eine Wegoptimierung, oder ist das eigentlich egal, wohin man schaut? Kann sich das Ding jederzeit drehen?
Nein, da gibt es zwei Möglichkeiten. Erstmal natürlich, wann so ein Objekt sichtbar ist. Denn du kannst nicht während des ganzen Jahres alles anschauen. Und da gibt es verschiedene, wir nennen das Constraints. Du darfst nicht in die Sonne schauen, du darfst nicht in den Mond schauen und so weiter. Das heißt, wir können nicht beliebig in beliebige Richtung schauen. Das, was wir anschauen können pro Tag, da sind wir flexibel. Wir können ein Sloo machen, von einem Objekt zum nächsten. Dann können wir den Satellit hintrehen, wo wir wollen, und dann bleiben wir auf einer bestimmten Richtung. Es gehört dann in die Aufgabe der Wissenschaft, zu sagen, was ist am wichtigsten anzuschauen, zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt. Da gibt es ein ganz klares Ranking, A-Ranking, B-Ranking und C-Ranking. Die A-Ranking müssen wir auf jeden Fall machen. Dann kommen die B-Ranking und irgendwann die C-Ranking. Da haben wir eine Liste von Sachen, die wir pro Jahr anschauen müssen. Dadurch entsteht unser sogenanntes Observation Schedule. Das schauen wir uns dann an. Die Daten gehen dann direkt wieder zurück nach Spanien, zum Science-Operation-Center, werden da ein bisschen aufbereitet. Dann gehen die zum Beobachter. Das ist meistens innerhalb von einer Woche oder so, hat er seine Daten. Dann darf er die Daten ein Jahr nur für sich behalten.
Also innerhalb einer Woche, ab dem Moment, wo sie eingefangen wurden?
Wo die Beobachtung gemacht worden ist, genau. Dann hat er das für ein Jahr, da gehören die nur ihm. Sind die privat. Dann darf er darüber eine Veröffentlichung schreiben. Wenn er dann nicht fertig ist in dem Jahr, gehen die dann an alle. Du darfst dir jetzt XMM-Daten runterladen, also in unserem Archiv von 2008, 2009. Die sind für jeden zugänglich. Und es ist ja nicht nur so, dass wir, wenn wir ein Objekt anschauen, nur Informationen von diesem einen Objekt haben. Unsere Kamera macht ja ein viel größeres Bild vom Himmel in dem Moment. Das heißt drum herum sind viele, viele Dinge, die man sich jetzt auch anschauen kann. Und das wird natürlich von anderen Beobachtern genutzt, die sich systematisch dann Bereiche des Himmels anschauen, von Daten, die inzwischen public sind, die für jeden zu haben sind, und da eine Menge an zusätzlichen Informationen rausziehen.
Also Beobachtungsabfall sozusagen.
Ja, das ist kein Abfall, das ist oft, ja, zusätzliche Menge nützliche Informationen. Und generell machen wir pro Jahr oder veröffentlichen unsere Wissenschaftler und unsere Community 300 Papers pro Jahr. Das sind jetzt mehr als 3000 schon. Und das ist eine sehr große Anzahl.
Für so eine Mission.
Das ist also schon ein stolzes, stolze Nummer, die wir da auffahren.
Jetzt haben wir schon einen weiten Bogen gespannt. Vielleicht nochmal so ein bisschen die Geschichte. Wollte ich nochmal ein bisschen in den Blick nehmen, wann das XMM gestartet?
1999 sind wir gestartet.
1999 und wahrscheinlich mit einer Ariane.
Mit einer Ariane 5. Und zwar war das die 504 damals. Das war die erste, die eigentlich wirklich erfolgreich gestartet ist. Wenn ich mich recht entzündet, dann ist die erste hatte ja ein Problem beim Start.
Die ist explodiert.
Die ist dann explodiert mit dem Cluster an Bord. Das war sehr schade. Und die zweite hatte dann, glaube ich, die Höhe nicht richtig erreicht. Und die dritte hatte dann nur ein Dummy an Bord. Das heißt, als wir auf dem Launchpad saßen damals, waren wir schon aufgeregt. Also ob das jetzt klappt oder nicht. Ich kann mich erinnern, ich war damals hier in ESOC auch als Student noch. Und da war man echt aufgeregt. Und man ist sowieso schon aufgeregt, wenn so ein Start ist. Man ist sowieso schon aufgeregt und fragt sich, ob das alles funktioniert und so. Und dann, ja, ging die ohne Probleme. Und was man sagen muss, nicht nur ohne Probleme, sondern viel besser als erwartet. Und dadurch haben wir sehr viel eigenen Sprit gespart bei XMM.
Das hast du vorhin schon erwähnt. Aber was bedeutet das, besser als erwartet? Also von was von der Toleranz muss man denn da ausgehen?
Na gut, wir rechnen in Kilogramm von Sprit. Und wir haben nach dem Start, glaube ich, 150 Kilogramm noch übrig gehabt. Und wir hätten auch wesentlich weniger übrig haben können. Also wir brauchen ungefähr fünf Kilogramm pro Jahr, um das XMM fliegen zu können. Kann ich vielleicht gleich noch mal drauf eingehen, warum man diesen Sprit überhaupt braucht. Und die ursprüngliche Missionszeit war vorgesehen für zwei bis zehn Jahre. Das heißt zehn Kilogramm pro für die zwei Jahre. Und dann noch mal ein bisschen was drauf. Und wir hatten eben wesentlich mehr. Und konnten dann den Flugbetrieb auch noch optimieren, sodass wir wesentlich länger jetzt noch beobachten können, als wir ursprünglich gedacht haben.
Der Sprit wird ja im Wesentlichen erst mal so von den Raketenstufen selbst verbraucht.
Die Rakete selbst hat ja einen eigenen Tank, den sie leer machen kann. Und wenn die Injection genau richtig läuft und perfekt läuft, hast du denn ein Satellit auf einer elliptischen Umlaufbahn. Und unsere Umlaufbahn sollte ungefähr so eine Ellipse um die Erde rumfliegen von 120.000 km Distanz. Das ist ungefähr eine Drittelmond-Entfernung mit einem Perigeeum. Das ist die nächste Stelle an der Erde von so 20.000 km und dann die weiteste Stelle weg. Das waren so 120.000 km. So, und wenn das jetzt nicht gestimmt hätte, dann hätten wir nochmal nachregeln müssen. Das war sozusagen fast nicht nötig. Wir mussten ein paar Burns machen, um den dann auf den perfekten Orbit zu kriegen, wie wir ihn wollten. Aber es hätte auch sein können, dass man wesentlich mehr benutzt. Und je mehr du am Anfang benutzt, um auf den richtigen Orbit zu kommen, desto weniger hast du natürlich am Schluss für die Operations übrig. Und du brauchst Sprit, dieses Hydrazin, nicht jetzt, um den Satellit zu drehen. Das machen wir alles mit Trollrädern. Wir haben also vier Trollräder an Bord. Die stehen mit ihrem Trollvektor in verschiedenen Richtungen. Und je nachdem, in welcher Geschwindigkeit du die drehst, das ist wie beim Fahrrad auch. Wenn du so ein Fahrrad mal mit dem Fahrradreifen drehst, und drehst ein bisschen rum, dann merkst du ja, da kommt eine Kraft. Und so machst du es hier umgekehrt. Du drehst das eine Rad in der Geschwindigkeit, das andere ein bisschen schneller. Und dadurch kannst du den Satellit im Orbit drehen. Das heißt, das machst du nur elektrisch über den Strom, den du von Solarzellen kriegst. Und jetzt ist es aber leider so, dass mit drei Rädern kannst du, wenn du vier, fünf Beobachtungen oder nicht mal drei, vier Beobachtungen pro Orbit machen willst, fliegen ja einmal um die Erde herum, das ist was wir in der Revolution nennen, dann kannst du da keinen perfekten Nullvektor fahren. Das heißt, im Endeffekt ist dir am Schluss von der Beobachtung, von der Revolution, ist dir ein bisschen Momentum, nennen wir das, übrig, dass du nicht mehr brauchen kannst für die nächste Revolution. Und du musst dann deine Räder wieder in eine Position bringen, dass du die nächsten Beobachtungen machen kannst. Und dafür brauchst du dann das Fuel, den Sprit. Das heißt, um die Räder jetzt zu entladen, da ist mehr Momentum drauf, als du brauchen kannst, feuerst du deine Düsen und kannst dann die Räder in einen Bereich wiederbringen, den du brauchst, um alle deine Beobachtungen machen zu können in der nächsten Revolution. Du musst also aus dem Satellit jetzt einen Moment rausnehmen, einen Drehmoment rausnehmen. Und das kann man durch die Düsen machen. Da machen wir so ein kleines, so nennt sich Reaction Wheel Bias, einmal pro Revolution, manchmal auch zweimal, kommt drauf an. Und dadurch verlieren wir immer ein bisschen Treibstoff.
Aber das sind immer nur so ganz kurze...
Das sind so ganz kurze... genau. Und die versucht man natürlich so kurz zu machen, wie möglich.
Das heißt, der Sprit wird gar nicht verwendet, um jetzt die Bahn zu halten. Die ist so hoch genug, dass der Kopf verlöst ist.
Das machen wir ganz tricky. Du brauchst da natürlich auch ein bisschen was, um die Bahn zu halten. Wir machen jetzt aber das Entladen von unseren Rädern an einem Moment, wo wir auch gleichzeitig dann noch die Bahn mit korrigieren können. Also das ist...
Man macht das sozusagen alles in einem Abmarsch.
Das machen wir in einem Abmarsch. Unsere Flugdynamiker, die können sich sowas ausrechnen. Wann wäre der beste Punkt, um auch den Orbit zu ändern? Und dann machen wir das so, dass wir beide Bedingungen erfüllen können.
Ja, verstehe. Das heißt, man gibt da einmal Energie rein und versucht das so zu machen, dass dieser Energieschub sowohl die Drollräder richtig entlädt, als auch den Orbit korrigiert. und den richtigen Energiezustand bringt, den man braucht, als eben auch gleichzeitig noch das gesamte Gefährt etwas anzuheben.
Genau, das ist die Idee.
Das funktioniert offensichtlich ganz gut.
Das funktioniert ganz gut, ja. Und da haben wir uns jetzt noch was Neues überlegt, denn wir haben ja vier Räder an Bord. Und die alte Technologie hat immer vorgesehen, dass man drei Räder aktiv anhat. Und das vierte war das Ersatzrad quasi, das Backup-Wheel. Und das wollte man eigentlich nur benutzen, wenn eins der anderen drei kaputt geht. Und da haben wir jetzt ein bisschen was gelernt von einem neuen ESA-Satelliten, der Hörschel.
Sind die denn alle gleich ausgerichtet?
Ja, die sitzen von ihrem Momentum-Vektor auf einem Tetraeder drauf. Sodass man sich vorstellen kann, also man darf jetzt nicht sich vorstellen, dass da eine Struktur ist von einer Pyramide und die sitzen an den Ecken, aber die Trägheitsmoment-Vektoren, die sitzen quasi an den Ecken. Und dadurch kann ich durch jedes Rad auch Komponenten in eine Richtung steuern, die ich von einem anderen Rad kann. Deshalb, wenn mir eins kaputt geht, kann ich das Viertel, das umgekehrt sitzt, dafür als Ersatz nehmen. Man muss dann zwar umkonfigurieren hier und da, aber das ist durchaus möglich. Aber wir hatten halt nur drei am Laufen. Und irgendwann, nach dem Start von Hörschel, dieser Infrarot-Mission, die die ESA seit einigen Jahren fliegt, kamen wir mal auf die Idee mit unserer Flugdynamik zusammen, warum machen wir das für XMM nicht auch, wie die das tun. Die haben nämlich vier Trauräder aktiv die ganze Zeit. Die haben sich gesagt, wenn wir vier haben, warum denn nicht alle vier benutzen? Weil dann hat man wesentlich mehr Möglichkeiten, um das Drehmoment zu bestimmen vom Satellit. Braucht weniger Sprit dafür. Die haben gesagt, wenn wir vier haben, dann können wir alle vier benutzen. Wenn eins kaputt geht, haben wir immer noch drei. Das reicht ja auch, aber warum nicht das Vierte von Anfang an mitbenutzen? Die haben gezeigt, dass man dadurch die Hälfte des Sprits einsparen kann. Mindestens, wenn nicht sogar mehr. Dann haben wir gesagt, wait a minute, das könnten wir doch auch machen. Und haben eine Studie betrieben in den letzten Jahren, um das anzuschauen. Es kam raus dabei bei Simulationen, dass wir auch die Hälfte an Sprit sparen können. Und jetzt wollen wir onboard unsere Software umschreiben, um die Missionszeit, um noch mal um Faktor 2 zu verlängern. Im Moment hätten wir noch Sprit bis 2020. Das heißt von jetzt auch noch mal acht Jahre. Und wenn wir jetzt mit vier Rädern fahren würden, dann hätten wir, wir nennen das Four-Wheel-Drive, so unter uns, wenn wir den Four-Wheel-Drive anmachen würden, dann könnten wir vielleicht bis 2027. Das ist natürlich noch mal eine ganz andere Perspektive. Und für uns natürlich wichtig, weil wir uns als Observatorium sehen, das noch ganz viel zu tun hat. Also wir haben unsere Mission nicht beendet. Wir finden immer noch mal was Neues. Wir können immer noch mal was Neues, Interessantes anschauen. Und das wäre natürlich toll, wenn wir das zu laufen kriegen. Das Problem dabei ist, dass wir live quasi die Software ändern müssen. Wir müssen also in ein laufendes Betriebssystem reinschreiben. Also wie eine OP am offenen Herzen.
Macht man eigentlich nicht so gerne.
Macht man nicht so gerne, genau. Das ist zwar nicht viel Code, was wir da ändern wollen. Und wir können das so ein bisschen vom Hörschel auch abgucken, wie das geht. Aber schneiden müssen wir dann selbst. Und der Satellit kann in dem Moment nicht abgeschaltet werden, sondern der bleibt an. Und wir müssen uns quasi so wie Münchhausen dann selbst aus der Grube rausziehen, indem wir dann einen neuen Softwareteil irgendwo hinschreiben in den Speicher, der nicht benutzt wird. Und dann der alten laufenden Software sagen, jetzt schalt mich an.
Das heißt, es gibt sozusagen gar keinen richtigen Reboot. Hier, neue Software, lad mal.
Nein, weil wenn du eine neue Software laden wolltest, komplett das löschen wolltest, hast du ja nichts mehr drauf. Und deshalb müssen wir in das Live-System reinschreiben. Und die Industrie ist ganz zuversichtlich, dass man das machen kann. Man hat das bei anderen Satelliten auch schon gemacht. Aber das ist, sagen wir mal, eine Sache, die macht man nicht in einem Monat. Da sind wir jetzt dran, mit verschiedenen Teams das nochmal aufzudröseln, alles, und wollen im September diese Onboardsoftware ändern. Und das ist auch ganz interessant, weil wir so eine alte Mission sind, dass man da jetzt wirklich mit Space Cowboys auch zusammenarbeitet. Also die Leute, die die Software geschrieben haben, sind inzwischen halt auch schon älter. Das ganze Projekt ging ja los dann Mitte der 80er-Jahre, wurde die Entwicklung angefangen, und die Jungs sind halt inzwischen in Rente. Und da muss man den einen oder anderen, musste man da aus der Rente wieder rausholen.
Das sind ja 2000 Probleme sozusagen.
Ja, noch mehr. Da muss man die wieder aktivieren. Und das macht sehr viel Spaß, muss ich sagen, mit solchen Cracks wirklich zusammenarbeiten, die sich nach so vielen Jahren an irgendwelche Details im Code erinnern. Und es können eigentlich nur die auch noch machen. Und da sind wir sehr gespannt, ob das jetzt funktionieren wird.
So wie bei alten Spionage-Filmen, wo man so an die Tür geklopft wird, das alte Team muss wieder zusammenkommen.
Das alte Team muss wieder zusammenkommen. Und die sind natürlich sehr froh, wenn sie da auch wieder gebraucht werden.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Das macht Spaß, mit solchen Jungs zusammenzuarbeiten.
Okay, das ist natürlich jetzt wirklich eine interessante Perspektive. Wie lange sollte es denn... Also was war denn, sagen wir mal, die pessimistischste Annahme? Oder was war so, sagen wir mal, die Mindesthaltbarkeit?
Die Mindesthaltbarkeit für XMM, oder das Requirement, war zwei Jahre plus acht, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere.
Also zwei Jahre musste es sozusagen...
Zwei Jahre war quasi Werftgarantie. Und danach, für acht Jahre, nochmal acht Jahre mehr, waren die Designs gemacht. Und jetzt hat man aber festgestellt, nach zehn Jahren, dass alles noch ohne Probleme funktioniert. Speziell die wissenschaftlichen Instrumente. Die sind also nicht wirklich sehr viel schlechter geworden. Wir haben ja da oben...
Also Ende 2009 sozusagen.
Und da hat sich herausgestellt, das funktioniert alles noch wunderbar. Es sind fast keine Strahlungsschäden da. Man kann ohne Probleme noch mit den Requirements, die wir gekriegt haben vom Start von den Wissenschaftlern, durchaus noch mal zehn Jahre weitermachen. Und da wir noch genug Sprit an Bord hatten, haben wir gesagt, okay, wir können mindestens jetzt vielleicht noch bis 2018 oder so machen. Und die Idee mit diesem 4-Wheel-Drive kam so 2010 rum. Ob man das nicht ausprobieren könnte. Und jetzt haben wir natürlich noch mal einen ganz anderen Horizont. Also 2018 ist eine Sache, 2028 ist eine ganz andere Sache. Es gibt natürlich keine Garantie mehr. Keiner kann sagen, alle Komponenten werden so lange halten. Aber man kann sich ja die Entwicklung von Strömen anschauen, wie viel so ein Ding zieht, bestimmte Subkomponenten. Und wenn sich da nichts dran verändert hat, also da nichts schlechter wird, kann man eigentlich sagen, wir sind fit. Wir können noch weitermachen.
Das ist ja schon langsam ein Kandidat für die längst laufende Mission.
Vielleicht, ja. Das muss man natürlich hier auf das Holz klopfen. Aber ein bisschen Glück gehört natürlich auch dazu. Aber generell, ich meine, wir haben so eine große Nachfrage. Das ist das Ding. Wir haben ja jetzt, wie gesagt, schon bei der letzten AO, sechsmal mehr Anfragen, als wir machen können. Das heißt, wenn wir heute...
AO ist...?
Die Announcement of Opportunity. Das, wo wir die Wissenschaftler fragen, was wollt ihr anschauen? Wenn wir jetzt die Wissenschaftler nicht mehr fragen würden, können wir eigentlich sechs Jahre weitermachen? Wir haben für sechs Jahre eigentlich Jobs zu tun. Natürlich machen wir das nicht. Wir fragen jedes Jahr neue, weil es ja neue Ideen immer gibt. Aber es sieht so aus, als ob diese Notwendigkeit, XMM zu betreiben, nicht abnimmt. Das ist natürlich dann auch für uns in Operations wichtig zu sehen. Es ist eine Notwendigkeit da, das weiter zu betreiben, um dann solche komplizierten Änderungen in einem Satellitensystem vorzunehmen.
Aber ganz problemlos war der Betrieb bisher auch noch nicht. Es gab da mindestens mal einen kleinen Zwischenfall.
Ja, es gibt immer Zwischenfälle. Ein Satellit kann sich ja in den sogenannten ESA-Mode schalten. Das ist der Emergency Sun Acquisition Mode. Das ist, wenn irgendwas auf dem Satellit komisch läuft, dann schaltet er im Prinzip auf ein BRAVO-System um, weil er nicht mehr sicher ist, dass das IFAS-System ordentlich läuft, schaltet alles ab, was nicht notwendig ist, und guckt mit den Solarzellen nur noch in die Sonne. Schaut, dass er also sicher Strom kriegt, dass er eine sichere Lageregelung hat, wartet dann, bis man wieder zurückschaltet. Das kommt auch mal vor, weil man was falsch gemacht hat. Man kann auch immer mal was falsch machen. Oder es kommt mal vor, weil ein Partikel aus der kosmischen Strahlung uns zum Beispiel irgendwas abgeschaltet hat. Das kann zum Beispiel auch vorkommen. Dass man so ein Partikel einfach ein Rad ausschaltet, ein Trialrad, und dass man dann... Ein Partikel. Ja, das sind so Protonen, hochenergische Protonen, oder je nachdem, was für eine Energie die haben, die dann eine Sicherung quasi bei uns aufmachen können. Da fliegt die Sicherung raus, und wenn die Sicherung in der falschen Stelle rausfliegt, dann hat man ein Problem. Wir hatten das zum Glück jetzt noch nicht bei XMM, aber bei unserem Schwester-Satellit, bei Integral, da hast du schon ein paar Mal vorgekommen, da haut dir dann einfach das Rad weg in dem Moment, und das geht dann aus, wird zu langsam, dann kriegt der Satellit, fängt an zu driften, das merkt die Elektronik, und dann schaltet sie ihn ab. Und da muss man rekammern. Das sind Sachen, die sind unangenehm, da muss man dann das ganze Team reinbringen für 24 Stunden, um den wieder hochzufahren, aber das hat man im Griff, das kriegt man hin. Wir hatten allerdings mal eine Situation in 2008, da hatten wir es nicht mehr im Griff. Denn da hatten wir plötzlich überhaupt keinen Kontakt mehr zum Satelliten gehabt. Und das war unangenehm, denn wenn man keinen Kontakt mehr hat, dann kann man auch nichts mehr tun. Es war still. Was heißt, man kann nichts mehr tun? Wenn du mit dem Ding nicht mehr reden kannst, dann kommst du nicht mehr rein und kannst auch nichts mehr rekonfigurieren. Und bei uns ist es so, bei XMM ist es so, wir haben keinen Speicherantwort, das heißt, wir müssen die ganze Zeit Kontakt zum Satelliten haben. Wir haben verschiedene Bodenstationen.
Um die Daten überhaupt auswerten zu können.
Um die Daten zu empfangen zu können. Und um Telekommandos überhaupt zum Satelliten hochzuschicken. Wir müssen ja die Instrumente umkonfigurieren. Wir müssen ihm sagen, dreh dich von da nach da. Da muss mehr Kommandos rutschen.
Also ist das kein Buffer?
Gar nichts. Die modernen Satelliten haben einen Speicher. Da schickst du eine sogenannte Timeline hoch. Die wird dann im Speicher abgespeichert und dann arbeitet er das ab. Nach ein paar Stunden oder Tagen lädst du die Daten runter und schickst ihm eine neue Timeline hoch. Das ging damals bei uns noch nicht. So gute Speicher gab es da noch nicht. Man wollte das auch nicht machen. Man wollte permanent Kontakt zum Satellit. D.h.
man muss auch diese ganzen Neuausrichtungen auch live machen? Das machen wir alles live.
Es ist nicht so, dass wir uns da hinsitzen an die Tastatur und hacken da Live-Kommandos rein. Sondern wir bereiten die Timeline der Kommandos vor. Das wird dann Stück für Stück hochgeschickt. Aber das ist schon vorbereitet. Kein Joystick. Nein, manchmal muss man auch so ein Joystick auspacken, aber sehr ungern. Da kann man immer Fehler machen mit dem Joystick. Und das, was wir dann haben, ist, wir haben drei Bodenstationen verteilt auf der Welt, über die wir den Satellit anschauen können. Weil die Erde dreht sich ja und der Satellit dreht sich. Deshalb siehst du nicht von immer überall den Satelliten.
Sind das immer dieselben Bodenstationen?
Nein, wir haben in Perth einen, in Australien, einen in Kourou, das ist in Südamerika. Dann haben wir noch in Villafranca in Spanien eine und noch ein paar Backup-Bodenstationen.
Aber meistens sind es die drei.
Meistens sind es die drei. Eigentlich brauchen wir nur zwei. Wir kommen aus mit Perth und mit Kourou. Mit den zwei. Aber manchmal müssen die repariert werden oder ein anderes Satellit ist mal drauf beim Start. Dann braucht man eine Alternativstation. Was wir also dann machen, ist, wir müssen manchmal von einer Bodenstation an die andere übergeben. Der Perth sieht ihn nicht mehr, der Kourou sieht ihn aber schon.
Und die Kourou auch zu S-Track?
Die gehören zu uns, ja, zu S-Track.
Okay, beides S-Tracks.
Beides S-Tracks. Und dann siehst du ihn noch auf der einen Station. Dann weißt du aber, demnächst muss ich abgeben. Dann muss die andere Station da reinloggen. Und es passiert manchmal, dass du zwischendrin aus irgendwelchen Gründen mal keinen Kontakt hast. Das kann passieren. Das macht es aber nicht schlimm. Dann kann man die Instrumente in eine Safe-Konfiguration fahren. Schaltest, machst quasi Klappen zu. Wartest, hörst du den Satellit.
Also das macht der Satellit sozusagen selbst?
Nein, das kommandieren wir vorher. Wir kommandieren auf der einen Bodenstation. Wir wissen, in zehn Minuten verlieren wir die Station. Dann machen wir alles zu. Dann haben wir, sagen wir mal, halbe Stunde keinen Kontakt. Und dann fangen wir in der anderen Bodenstation wieder auf. Wir können uns genau ausrechnen, wann der quasi aus diesem Gap wieder rauskommt. Das kommt mal vor, das haben wir auch im Griff. Und was man da manchmal machen muss, ist die Antenne umzuschalten. Wir haben zwei Antennen. Die schauen in zwei verschiedene Richtungen. Du kommst jetzt in der Richtung geflogen. Wir müssen ja den Satellit ausrichten, auch in verschiedene Richtungen. Und da ist es manchmal notwendig, auf eine andere Antenne dann zu gehen. Also am Satellit die Antenne.
Kann jetzt diese Antenne separat bewegt werden? Nee, die wird nicht bewegt.
Wir haben zwei festinstallierte Antennen.
Das heißt, man muss den ganzen Satelliten bewegen?
Nee, nee. Du lässt den Satellit so stehen. Hast aber jetzt eine andere Bodenstation, musst also von der Bodenstation auf die gehen, musst die Antenne am Satellit erinnern, hast du einen Schalter, der schaltet die eine Antenne drüber.
Also man schaltet nur oben sozusagen?
Schaltest drüber, genau. Das machen wir standardmäßig. Das kann man auch automatisch machen mit dem sogenannten Timetag an Bord. Das heißt, du hast ein Kommando an Bord. Wir haben einen mini kleinen Speicher, wo wir ein paar Kommandos speichern können. Der weiß, um die Zeit, wenn ich in einem Gap bin, schalte ich meine Antenne um. Plopp. Wenn ich aus dem Gap rauskomme, sieht die andere Bodenstation die Antenne. Das haben wir oft gemacht. Das funktionierte ohne Bord.
Okay, also so ein paar Kommandos haben sozusagen eine Speicherfunktion mit eingebaut, aber es gibt halt keinen generellen Speicher für Kommandos?
Und das haben wir auch gemacht damals. Und wir sind in diesen Gap reingeflogen. Satellit ROSAT kam raus aus dem Gap. Kein Kontakt mehr. Also wir haben nichts mehr gesehen. Gar nichts. XMM-Newton antwortet nicht. Genau. Und da ist natürlich die erste Idee, die man da kriegt, ist Bodenstation. Irgendetwas mit der Bodenstation faul. Bodenstation trackt auf der falschen Frequenz. Kommt mal vor, laden die ein falsches File rein, kann mal passieren. Oder Bodenstation weiß den Orbit nicht richtig, guckt in die falsche Richtung, kann alles passieren. Oder generell das Problem bei der Bodenstation. Was man dann zuerst macht, ist Orbit checken. Diese Files, war alles richtig. Dann sagt man, okay, lass mal warten.
Wie checkt man das? Dann checkt man das aber zusammen mit dem Trupp von S-Track zusammen.
Genau, die S-Track.
Also man nimmt da direkt Kontakt auf.
Ja, wir können ja direkt mit denen reden. Dann kann man gucken, habt ihr die letzten Orbit-Files von uns, oder ist das korrekt und so. Das war alles in Ordnung. Dann sagt man, okay, vielleicht ist da was, was wir nicht verstehen bei der Bodenstation. Kann ja sein. Lass uns mal warten, bis wir auf die nächste Bodenstation kommen, die wir vorher hatten. Da hat es ja funktioniert. Da müssten wir ja wieder Kontakt kriegen. Sind wir auf die Bodenstation gekommen, war auch nichts.
Wie lange sind wir so einmal rum? 90 Minuten?
Nein, wir fliegen ja ganz lange in Orbit. Wir fliegen in 48 Stunden Orbit. Zwei Tage. Da muss man dann schon mal ein paar Stunden warten. So muss man nur 24 Stunden warten, bis man auf der anderen Bodenstation ist. War da auch nichts. Haben wir mit der dritten Bodenstation draufgeschaut, war auch nichts. Da wurde es uns dann schon unangenehm. Aber dann dachte, es kann ja alles Mögliche sein. Die erste Idee ist, getroffen worden von irgendwas. Space Debris, irgendein Stückchen, hat uns getroffen, hat uns zerstört. Kann natürlich sein. Oder hat uns nur an einem Teil getroffen, der Satellit dreht sich also die ganze Zeit und kann sich nicht mehr selbst regulieren. Könnte auch sein. Kann man natürlich von unten nicht sehen. Wir haben ja keinen Sichtkontakt. Sonnenwind ist so klein, der kann eigentlich relativ wenig machen. Es hätte aber zum Beispiel sein können, dass unser Transmitter ausgeschaltet worden ist. Das ist uns schon mal passiert auch, dass der Transmitter, der die Information nach unten schickt, der hat quasi eine Sicherung auch. Wenn die aufgeht, durch so ein Protonen-Event, Single Event Upset, was da reinhaut, kann das aufgehen. Das kann man aber wieder anschalten, weil die Receivers, die sind immer an, die kann man nicht ausschalten. Satellit hört immer, spricht aber nicht. Das heißt, du kannst Kommandos ins Blinde schicken und machst dann den Schalter wieder zu und dann redet er wieder mit dir. Das haben wir ausprobiert, hat nicht funktioniert. Also war es das auch nicht. Und dann kriegt man langsam Angst. Dann denkt man, oh, da ist doch irgendwas kaputt. Also was Massives. Aber wir haben dann alle Daten angeschaut, bis zu dem Kontaktverlust. Das war alles perfekt. Manchmal sieht man irgendeinen Strom ansteigen, was man schon mal weiß, da kann was kaputt gehen. Das war alles perfekt. Bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo wir Kontakt verloren haben, war es perfekt. Und dann haben wir damals schon überlegt, oh, mit dem Schalter. Vielleicht ist ja mit dem Schalter irgendwas komisch, der diese Antennen hin und her schaltet. Wir haben dann auch die Industrie gefragt, wie ist das denn mit dem Schalter? Kann der irgendwie vielleicht da nicht schalten? Dann haben die gesagt, nein. Der ist so designt, entweder wenn der nicht schaltet und kaputt geht, dann fällt er an die Stellung A wieder zurück. Oder er ist auf der Mitte durch und dann fällt er auf die Stellung B. Der kann nicht irgendwie stecken bleiben. Der ist entweder so oder so. Oder er macht gar nichts, dann bleibt er, wo er war.
Also mechanisch wird das sozusagen sichergestellt?
Genau, also das ist wie das gebaut ist. Kann das eigentlich gar nicht passieren. Das war uns schon ein bisschen dubios. Wir haben hier so ein Modell von dem Schalter bei uns quasi im Keller stehen. Wir haben dann versucht, die Stromstöße, die man an den schickt, ein bisschen zu ändern. Die Pulses. Dann haben wir es in relativ kurzer Zeit hingekriegt, dass der also genau in der Mitte stehen bleibt. Oha! Das darf eigentlich gar nicht passieren. Wir haben die Industrie angerufen und gesagt, das geht doch. Guckt mal, wenn die mich da hingucken, haben die auch gesagt, oha. Und das war am Punkt, wo wir gesagt haben, das ist ja gar nicht so schlecht dann. Wenn sonst nichts kaputt ist, außer dem Schalter, dann gibt es ja vielleicht noch eine Chance.
Aber das heißt auch dann, dass im Prinzip keine der Antennen mehr empfängt oder sendet? Also geht es jetzt nur um...
Gar nichts. Wenn die Antenne nicht auf dem Satellit geschaltet ist, das ist wie, wenn du den Stecker ziehst. Du hast zwar noch deine Antenne.
Also kann man mit dem Ding gar nicht reden.
Du kannst mit ihm nicht reden. Und das wäre jetzt eine schöne... Immerhin war er aber nicht kaputt dadurch. Und dann haben wir mit ein paar optischen Astronomen angefangen, unsere Bahn nachzuvollziehen und haben wirklich hingeschaut, ist der XMM noch da, wo er sein soll? Und haben dann einen Punkt gesehen, der sich da bewegt auf dem Orbit. Und der Punkt hat auch nicht geflackert. Flackern heißt, dass der Satellit sich drehen würde. Weil die kriegen ja hauptsächlich Reflektionen von den Solarzellen. Und das wussten wir schon mal, okay, er dreht sich auch nicht. Und dann haben wir die ganze Armee rausgeholt, was die ESA zur Verfügung hat. Alle mögliche Drecking-Teleskope, wo man wirklich sehr kleine Bruchstücke sehen kann. Ich glaube, bis 30 cm oder so.
Also hier ist ja sozusagen richtig Alarm dann auch beim ESA. Das ist sozusagen wirklich eine der schlimmen Dinge, die passieren können.
Und da sind dann auch alle Abteilungen, lassen die Leitstifte frei. Du kannst als Spacecraft Operations Manager einen sogenannten Spacecraft Emergency deklarieren. Da sagst du also hier, mein Satellit braucht Hilfe. Und dann kriegst du alles, was zur Verfügung steht. Alle Bodenstationen und so weiter. Das sollte man nicht aus Spaß machen. Das ist dann ernst. Nicht Lübe brüllen, ja.
Aber das war jetzt schon klar. Das war dann klar.
Und dann haben wir auch gesehen, dass er nicht in zwei Stücke zerbrochen ist. Und dann haben wir gesagt, okay, dann ist das vielleicht doch das mit dem Schalter. Und haben gesagt, komm, jetzt können wir einfach Astronomen spielen. Und sagen, der XMM ist jetzt ein Radiostern. Weil, wenn dieser Schalter in der Mitte sitzt, das darf man sich nicht so vorstellen, dass das wirklich das Kabel abgezogen ist. Sondern das ist nur ein bisschen locker. Das heißt, der funkt nicht mehr so mit aller Kraft runter. Aber so ein bisschen. So ein bisschen tut der vielleicht noch. Und dann haben wir eine Antenne, die wir haben, umkonfiguriert. In wissenschaftlichen Beobachtungsmod, im Prinzip. Und haben quasi nach einem Radiosternen gesucht, der auf dem Orbit, auf der Umlaufbahn vom XMM fliegt.
Also eine Antenne vom S-TRAC?
Ich glaube, das war eine, die Neunorscher Antenne gewesen, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Eine S-TRAC-Antenne. Einfach so eine, war es eine Neunorscher? Ich kann mich nicht mehr erinnern.
Also eine, die jetzt überhaupt nicht für die Beobachtung des Welts gedacht ist?
Ja, die kann man auf Radio-Mode auch umschalten. Okay, also ihr habt so ein Modus, aber wird in der Regel sehr wenig betrieben. Dafür nicht benutzt. Ich muss jetzt mal sagen, welche das war. Ich kann mich gerade nicht mehr erinnern. Jedenfalls haben wir mit der dann in die Richtung von XMM geschaut und mitgeschaut. Und dann haben wir ein ganz kleines Signal gesehen. Und das hat auch gepasst von der Frequenz her. Also dann konnten wir sagen, da ist noch was. Der ist nicht mehr so fit, aber da ist noch Leben. Und wenn er sendet, dann müsste er ja auch empfangen, sozusagen. Das war die Idee. Aber jetzt konntest du dir ausrechnen über das, was noch durchkommt. Das, wenn wir mit einer normalen Sendekraft dahinschicken, das hätte nicht ausgereicht. Du kannst dir ausrechnen, du weißt, wie viel der senden soll, wie viel unten ankommt. Dann kannst du dir das Delta überlegen. Mit dem, wo du quasi ein Signal hochschicken müsstest. Hätte also mit unserer normalen Station nicht gereicht. So ein starkes Signal können wir nicht senden. Dann haben wir unsere amerikanischen Kollegen in Goldstone angerufen. Da gibt es eine ganz große 30-Meter-Antenne. Mit dieser großen Antenne könnte man das machen. Die haben einen sehr starken Sender dort. Die haben gebeten, ob sie nicht ihre Anlage umkonfigurieren können für uns und ein Kommando hochschicken. Aber wir können das nicht. Alle politischen Schranken sind da gefallen. Die haben uns geholfen. Wir hatten dann quasi so one-shot. Wir haben dann das Kommando geschickt, um den Schalter wieder zurückzulegen. Wir haben uns vorher überlegt, wie stark das sein muss. Da muss man aufpassen. Das war ein ziemlich starkes Funk-Signal. Da darf keine Kuh im Weg stehen. Die hätte es dann gegrillt.
Das ist wie bei Star Wars, wenn der Tod des Sterns sich den Planeten vornimmt.
Dann hat man auch nicht so viele Chancen. Wir haben das dann ausprobiert. Was kann man verlieren?
Hätte der Satellit auch selber Schaden nehmen können?
Wusst man nicht, das hat man noch nie gemacht. Das macht man nicht so gern.
Was für eine Energie muss da zusammengebündelt werden?
Jetzt fragst du mich wieder, dann musst du unsere Bodenstationen fragen.
Also faktormäßig 10-fache, 100-fache?
Ich glaube, es war mehr. Wir wissen es nicht mehr. 2000 Watt oder so was. Ich kann es mal rausfinden und dir wieder sagen. Es war jedenfalls sehr viel. Das hat man dann hochgeschickt. Und dann innerhalb einer Sekunde war das Signal wieder da. Pipe, Pipe, Pipe hat er dann wieder gemacht. Seitdem benutzen wir den Schalter nicht mehr. Das ist uns also zu gefährlich.
Das heißt, es bleibt nur noch die eine Schüssel?
Nein, das dachten wir am Anfang auch. Dann hätten wir um die Hälfte unserer Beobachtungszeit reduzieren müssen. Aber es gibt eine Möglichkeit. Wir haben ja Redudanz immer an Bord. Das heißt, wir haben so ein paar Backup-Transmitter auch. Und wir schalten jetzt einfach den zweiten an, wenn wir die zweite Antenne brauchen. Und brauchen deshalb diesen Switch nicht mehr. Wir können die zweite Antenne über einen anderen Weg ansprechen. Wir schalten dann diese Transmitter an und aus. Und dadurch müssen wir den Switch nicht mehr benutzen. Wir glauben gar nicht so wirklich, dass er richtig kaputt ist. Wir glauben, wenn wir ihn zum Beispiel zweimal schalten würden, einfach so einen Doppelkick geben, dann müsste er funktionieren. Aber das Risiko ist uns einfach zu hoch. Das ist so ein Spruch, den es hier immer gibt. Safe, Safety First und Safety First Kick killt dann sowas. Wir wollen es auch nicht nochmal ausprobieren, ob er geht. Denn wer würde wieder stecken bleiben und wer weiß, ob wir dann dieses starke Signal nochmal senden können. Deshalb machen wir das jetzt mit den Zwei-Transmittern, solange wie es geht.
Verständlich. Da geht einem das Herz aber auch in die Hose, oder? In dem Moment so?
Schon, ja. Man ist ja lange mit so einem Ding beschäftigt. Und dann überlegt man sich halt, was wäre wenn. Und da hängt ja nicht nur hier das Flugkontrollteam dran mit unseren Leuten hier, sondern da hängt ja eine ganz große wissenschaftliche Community auf der ganzen Welt dran. Und das wäre natürlich schon schade, wenn die plötzlich nichts mehr zu tun hätten.
Du hast ja vorhin gesagt, dass das Ding mehrere Instrumente hat. Und eins davon ist auch ein optisches Instrument. Oder habe ich das falsch verstanden?
Ja, es gibt dann unser Optical Monitor.
Was heißt das, dass er da mal nicht im...
Der guckt parallel im optischen Bereich noch mit. Also wenn du ein XMM-Daten-Set kriegst, dann kriegst du zwei Spektren von den Spektrometern, von den RGSs, du kriegst zwei Bilder von den MOS-Kameras und noch ein Bild von der PN-Kamera. Mit diesen drei Bildern kannst du aber auch Spektroskopie machen. Und dann kriegst du noch mal ein Datenset im optischen Bereich. Das kannst du als Beobachter vorher konfigurieren, wie du willst. Du kannst sagen, mach mir beim optischen Monitor den und den Filter rein, operiert mir die Kamera in dem und dem Modus, schnell, langsam, kleines Gesichtsfeld, großes Gesichtsfeld, je nachdem wie du willst. Kann man alles einstellen. Je nachdem, wie dein Objekt aussieht. Wenn du eine Galaxie anschauen willst, auflösen, dann brauchst du viel Platz von deinem CCD. Wenn du nur ein kleines Objekt wie einen Röntgen-Doppelstern anschauen willst, der aber sehr schnell pulst, dann machst du das CCD nicht überall an, sondern nur ein kleines Window an, kannst aber dann viel schneller auslesen, weil der Bereich drum herum interessiert dich gar nicht. So kann man die Kameras für jede Beobachtung konfigurieren. Und wenn du sagst, mein Objekt ist im optischen Bereich auch interessant, kannst du halt parallel optisch noch mitschauen. Und das ist sehr interessant, weil du dann keine Bodenzeit bei einem optischen Teleskop beantragen musst.
Das heißt, XMM-Newton könnte uns mit ein bisschen Glück noch richtig lange erhalten. Also bleibt jetzt sowieso schon noch relativ lange. Also die zehn Jahre, wenn jetzt nichts Besonderes passiert, scheinen ja schon mal sicher zu sein. Aber es könnte dann eben, wenn das mit dem Software-Upgrade funktioniert, sogar noch länger sein. Oder auch sehr viel kürzer.
Nein, also die Idee ist, dass wir da eigentlich nichts wirklich kaputt machen können. Das Einzige, was passieren könnte, ist, dass wir das Ding mal kurz auf den Rücken legen und dann wieder aus diesem Emergency-Mode wieder zurückkommen müssten. Das wäre natürlich sehr unangenehm, aber wir testen das ja vor alles. Wir haben einen Simulator am Boden, der den XMM 1 zu 1 abbildet. Und da können wir das vorher testen. Und die Idee ist, dass wir das ohne Probleme eigentlich uploaden können. Muss man sehen, ob es wirklich klappt, aber eigentlich sind wir da ganz guter Hoffnung. Und dann könnten wir, wenn sonst nichts kaputt geht, denke ich mal schon noch bis Mitte der 20er operieren. Das wäre schon sinnvoll, wenn wir das hinkriegen würden.
Würdest du das Projekt dann gar nicht mehr los, sozusagen?
Dann würde ich das Projekt gar nicht mehr loswerden, ja. Aber da hat man sich inzwischen schon so dran gewöhnt. Und es gibt ja auch immer wieder was Spannendes zu machen. Und für mich, ich fühle mich immer noch so ein bisschen nicht nur als Spacecraft-Operations-Manager, sondern ein bisschen auch als Wissenschaftler noch. Also ich habe ja in Röntgen-Astronomie promoviert. Und für mich macht es natürlich auch immer wieder Spaß, die ganzen Ergebnisse zu sehen, und die Publikationen zu lesen und Dinge, die ich im Studium noch gelernt habe, als das weiß man nicht, was es genau ist. Wissen wir jetzt durch XMM, es ist wahrscheinlich das, zum Beispiel Gamma-Ray Bursts, wusste man zu meiner Zeit im Studium noch nicht. In der Vorlesung, was das genau ist, hat man verschiedene Theorien gehabt. Jetzt geht man davon aus, diese Gamma-Plitze, die plötzlich im Universum irgendwo hochkommt. Und da sind wir mit XMM jetzt ein großes Stück weiter bekommen. Und wissen, dass das entweder massive Supernova-Explosionen sind oder so ein Neutronenstern-Merger. Man weiß es jetzt nicht wirklich ganz genau. Es ist das, aber man hat diese große Anzahl von Möglichkeiten schon mal sehr reduzieren können. Weil beim Gamma-Ray Burst ist es ganz wichtig, dass man möglichst schnell nach dem Gamma-Ray Burst draufgeht. Und dafür haben wir sogenannte Target of Opportunities eingerichtet. Das heißt, wenn irgendwo ein Observatorium ein Gamma-Ray Burst detected hat, das kann auch auf dem Boden passieren, dann machen die eine Warnung. Das gibt es über ein Netzwerk, über die ganze Welt. Und dann kriegen wir einen Trigger bei uns. Und dann können wir ausrechnen, wie lange brauchen wir, um auf das Objekt drauf zu suchen.
Wie taucht dieser Trigger auf? Fangen dann an, rote Lampen zu...
Nee, nee, das kommt per E-Mail erst mal an. Und dann ins Mission-Kontrollsystem kommt es dann noch mal mit einem roten Trigger auch. Und dann wird zuerst mal das Science Center aktiv in Spanien. Die schauen sich dann an, würden wir da überhaupt theoretisch hinkommen, so schnell? Weil du musst innerhalb von ein paar Stunden auf dem Objekt drauf sein, sonst siehst du da nichts mehr.
Das heißt, man muss sich überhaupt erst mal an der richtigen Stelle befinden, da darf die Sonne nicht dazwischen sein, nicht der Mond, etc.
Genau, wir müssen dahin drehen. Manchmal sind wir auch ziemlich nah dran, aus Zufall gerade. Wir müssen die normale Beobachtung abbrechen und dann ins SLU ausrechnen, wie kommen wir dahin, während des SLU's Instrumente umkonfigurieren und dann möglichst schnell beobachten. Deshalb haben wir einen On-Call-Service, also einen Wissenschaftler, der hat die ganze Zeit ein Handy dabei, sind mehrere natürlich, dass wir da 24 Stunden abdecken können, und der kriegt dann einen Anruf.
Für die Falle, dass es irgendwo einen Gammablitz gibt.
Genau, der kommt dann reingefahren, rechnet sich aus, kommen wir dahin, und dann ruft der den Projekt-Scientist an und sagt, pass auf, wie ist das, sollen wir das machen? Weil die Beobachtung, die wir machen, muss ja abgebrochen werden. Und der Projekt-Scientist sagt dann Ja oder Nein, und dann geht es los.
Man muss abschätzen, ob das jetzt sozusagen wert ist, die unter Umständen auch wichtige Beobachtung, die man gerade macht, weil die unter Umständen auch so nicht fortgesetzt werden kann.
Die ist erst mal dann verloren, das ist klar. Und dann geht es los, dann müssen also Leute reinkommen, die sich diese Pointing-Änderung ausrichten müssen. Und da geht es dann wirklich um Stunden. Das muss man möglichst schnell hinkriegen. Dass man das innerhalb von vier, fünf Stunden hinkriegt, ist dann gut. Und wenn man dann möglichst schnell auf so einem Objekt drauf ist, dann kann man ein ganz frühes Spektrum in dieser Entwicklungszeitraum messen. Und das ist interessant. Und da haben wir zum Beispiel mal ein Spektrum auch gemessen, das vielleicht in die Richtung deutet, dass es sich darum Supernova handelt, weil das Spektrum ähnlich aussieht. Das siehst du aber wirklich nur die ersten paar Stunden in diesem Röntgen-Afterglow. Danach sieht man es dann schon wieder nicht mehr. Und das sind so Sachen, die sind echt spannend.
Wie oft ist das so vorgekommen?
Gamma-revers sind am Anfang öfter vorgekommen. Da hat man das vielleicht mal alle paar Monate gehabt. Inzwischen gibt es einen anderen Satelliten, den Swift. Der kann das schneller als wir. Und der hat uns da ein bisschen Job abgenommen. Da sind wir aber ganz froh drüber, weil der einfach wissenschaftlich gesehen dann halt schneller dran ist. Das ist ein autonomerer Satellit, ein kleinerer auch, der da schneller drauf gucken kann. Der übrigens eine Kamera an Bord hat, die die gleiche ist, die wir auch fliegen. Also so ein Beiprodukt eigentlich vom XMM auch wieder. Und in letzter Zeit haben wir nicht mehr so viele direkte ToOs für Gamma-Rebursts. Dafür machen wir jetzt quasi ein neues Business. Das nennt sich Triggered Observation. Dadurch, dass wir so viele neue oder alte, erkannte Objekte genauer angeguckt haben, wissen wir, dass die sich zeitlich verändern. Jetzt wissen wir aber nicht, wann die sich verändern. Solche Röntgen-Doppelsterne, die machen manchmal ganz komische Dinge. Das kannst du nicht vorhersagen. Du weißt nur, der geht von einem Status in den anderen. Und dann schreiben viele Beobachter jetzt Proposals, die sagen, ich möchte das in das Objekt anschauen, aber erst dann, wenn es diese Besonderheit zeigt. Und dann geben die uns wiederum einen Trigger. Und das können dann nur wir machen, weil wir halt diese guten Spektren herstellen können. Das heißt, wir haben dann auch wieder Target of Opportunity, aber oft nicht mehr für einen Gamma-Reburst, sondern für ein anderes Objekt. Was sich herausgestellt hat, dass es sehr, sehr interessant ist und sehr wichtig ist, erst durch XMM, dadurch, dass wir mehr über diese Objekte gelernt haben.
Das ist auch so ein bisschen so eine geskriptete Beobachtung, dass man dann so einfache ÖVSEN-Programme quasi im Ablauf dadurch definiert, dass man sagt, okay, wir beobachten das und wenn dort an der Stelle die und die Veränderung eintritt, dann gehen wir dahin. Dann ändert sich das Gesamtprogramm, dann muss man da nochmal beigehen, etc. Und das wird natürlich jetzt dann noch sehr viel intensiver in dem Moment, wo man dann sehr viel länger beobachten kann.
Genau, und je mehr man gelernt hat, desto mehr Ideen kriegt man ja auch, um neue Sachen zu beobachten oder nochmal näher ranzuschauen. Und das ist, wie gesagt, das Tolle beim XMM, dass man, egal wo man hinschaut, immer nochmal so viele neue Sachen entdeckt. Durch diese Tiefe, durch diese große Anzahl der Spiegel hat man jedes Mal, bei jeder Beobachtung, wenn es gar nicht mehr ums zentrale Objekt geht drum herum, gibt es so viele neue Dinge, die gefunden werden, dass man da einen Überfluss an Informationen hat, um immer wieder was Neues zu finden.
So andere Beispiele für wissenschaftliche Ergebnisse, die die Beobachtung befördert, beflügelt, zumindest begleitet hat?
Es gibt ganz viele Sachen. Ich glaube, da muss man wirklich auf die Webpage schauen. Wir haben da so einen Ticker, wo alle Monate mal wieder ein neues Event gefeaturet wird. Das geht von Biss. Also jetzt da Sachen rauszupicken, wird man der Mission nicht gerecht. Dann kriege ich dann in einer Stunde drei Anrufe von Leuten, die mir sagen, warum hast du meine Sachen nicht erzählt und so.
Ja, das ist klar.
Das möchte ich mir an dieser Stelle zurückhalten.
Dass die alle eine bestimmte Bedeutung haben, das ist natürlich auch klar. Haben wir denn noch etwas ganz Wichtiges vergessen?
Was ganz wichtig ist, was man noch vier von ESA auf jeden Fall sagen sollte, ist die Aufgabe unserer Spacecons. Das ist etwas, was ich immer gerne an dieser Stelle sage. So ein Team ist ja aufgebaut in verschiedenen Layers. Du hast natürlich den Spacecraft Operations Manager, den Chef, der ich quasi bin. Und ich habe ein paar Ingenieure, die dann für mich arbeiten und unser Programm implementieren. Und dann die Leute, die wirklich das Spacecraft fliegen. Das sind die Spacecraft-Controller. Die müssen in Tag- und Nachtschichten Prozeduren hochladen und wirklich die Arbeit machen. Und das sind Leute, die vergisst man manchmal so, weil die sind halt an der Front sozusagen. Aber die machen den Job. Und das ist vielleicht etwas, was ich an dieser Stelle hier über, darf man Älter noch sagen, wenn das über das Internet läuft?
Na ja, wenn XMM die Existenz des Äters später dann nachweist, kein Problem.
Also über den Podcast, den Netz-Äter hier wegschicken möchte. Bei denen möchte ich mir an dieser Stelle nochmal bedanken, weil die machen unseren Job eigentlich. Und die machen viel Arbeit. Und denen verdanken wir ganz, ganz viel. Weil die sich unheimlich dafür engagieren, dass unser Projekt so smooth läuft. Also um mal ein Beispiel zu sagen, wir kriegen fast 99,9% unserer Daten runter. Das würde nicht laufen, wenn diese ganzen Jungs nicht so gut und so verantwortungsvoll arbeiten würden. Und das muss man an dieser Stelle nochmal ein ganz klares Dankeschön in diese Richtung sagen. Das ist echt ein super Team, was wir da zusammen haben. Und Spacecon ist ein interessanter Job auch. Es ist ein anstrengender Job, weil man im Ernstfall, wenn wirklich Notfälle passieren, ganz, ganz schnell handeln muss und auch keine Fehler machen darf. Weil wenn man was falsch macht, kann man im schlimmsten Fall eine Mission gefährden. Aber es ist glaube ich auch ein ganz erfüllender Job, weil man halt wirklich an der Front ist und so einen Spacecraft fliegen darf. Und ja, das ist einfach nochmal...
Ein Raumschiff-Pilot eigentlich.
Ja, das kann man schon so sagen. Natürlich darf man bei so einer Mission nicht vergessen, gibt es ganz viele... jede Position ist ganz wichtig. Also unsere Ingenieure sind auch ganz wichtig, die wirklich das Wissen haben vom Spacecraft. Die wissen, das kann ich mit den Solarzellen machen, das kann ich mit den Trialrädern machen, das kann ich mit meinem Radiofrequency-System machen. Das ist natürlich die Brains auch, die wirklich jede Schraube da kennen.
Letztlich kommt es in der Raumfahrt wirklich immer auf jeden an. Und vor allem, dass auch jeder die Arbeit der anderen im Blick hat.
Das ist ganz wichtig. Kommunikation ist ganz wichtig in dem Bereich, auf das man mit den anderen redet. Lack of information ist eine der schlimmsten Sachen, die es gibt. Wenn einer etwas dem anderen nicht weitersagen würde, dann hat man ein Riesenproblem. Aber das ist in ESA eigentlich sehr schön. Man kriegt Informationen von allen, die sind alle sehr dankbar, Informationen zu kriegen, Informationen zu geben. Man ist eine große Familie, das funktioniert schön. Das ist also ein schöner Bereich von dem Job hier, muss man schon sagen.
Ja, da haben wir jetzt auch wieder einen weiteren Beitrag zugeleistet und mal diese Informationen noch in den Netz-Eta auch noch hinausgebracht. Ja, Marcus, vielen Dank für die spannenden Ausfälle. Ich merke auch immer wieder, umso komplizierter die Missionsbezeichnungen sind und so kryptischer die Abkürzungen, umso spannender wird es. Und ja, das war ein super Einblick hier in die Röntgen-Beobachtungsmission XMM-Newton. Vielen Dank nochmal und vielen Dank auch hier fürs Zuhören. Es geht bald weiter mit Raumzeit.